quand j'ai vu que j'allais être présent
aujourd'hui parmi vous on a mis jules
m'avait dit tu verras ça va être sympa
t'ai dit que c'est un truc pour toi je
me suis dit tu as raison ça va être mon
heure de gloire je vais enfin parler de
ce qui me passionne de ce qu'il fait
avancer dans la vie je vais enfin
aborder les vraies questions de société
je vais enfin parler de l'environnement
de l'écologie du changement climatique
la construction bioclimatique l'endroit
s'y prête nous sommes dans un
amphithéâtre bioclimatique
alors j'ai préparé mon talk jeu les
super bien préparés comme le bon devenir
que je suis très structuré avec des
chiffres des trucs très bien et puis
j'ai présenté aux organisateurs ceux là
mêmes qui nous font défiler
j'ai fait ma répète samedi dernier comme
un grand et à la fin de ma répète je fus
surpris parce que j'ai eu droit à une
standing-ovation c'était vraiment un
truc de fou tout le monde était là je me
suis dit c'est bon j'ai assuré truqués
bon y'a pas de soucis je peux partir
tranquille en fait ils m'ont dit tu as
fait un truc sympa mais vraiment très
sympa mais ça en fait une conférence ce
changement climatique
c'est pas un talk chabon donc en fait on
truque l'euro met dans la poche à ce que
tu ai dit que c'est pas ça j ok d'accord
valentées dit que c'est quoi battez dit
que c'est toi il faut que tu parle de
toi j'ai de moi on attend dé moi je
parle jamais de moi je parle de ce que
je fais de ce qui me passionne de ce qui
fait avancer dans la vie mais je ne
parle jamais de man fait parce que
parler de moi ça me renvoie des choses
qui sont pas forcément toujours agréable
et je suis rentré chez moi j'ai pris un
cigare je vous dis bon alors qu'est ce
que je vais bien le raconter fait chier
je vais vraiment leur dire les choses
veulent que je parle de moi je vais
vraiment leur dire les choses
et jusqu'à hier après midi il ne savais
pas ce que j'allais leur raconter parce
que je n'aurais pas envoyer mon texte
donc si tedx c'est parler de soi s'était
dit que c'est offrir quelque chose à
l'autre ce que j'ai envie de faire ce
matin c'est toucher votre coeur je vais
essayer de toucher votre coeur sur cette
photo la dame que vous voyez c'est ma
mère elle est décédée il ya deux ans
tragiquement
je n'ai pas eu le temps de lui dire ce
que j'avais toujours rêvé lui dire parce
que j'étais toujours en train de
travailler travailler travailler cette
femme
sa vie a basculé à l'âge de 14 ans mon
grand père qui rentrait de son travail a
été leur terme au dos par un bus et il
décida donc elle se retrouve à 14 ans
obligé de quitter sa scolarité et là je
m'adresse à tous ses étudiants qui sont
confortablement assis dans le siège
parce qu'il faut qu'ils prennent
conscience de la chance qu'ils ont
d'aller à l'école et d'étudier à 14 ans
elle se retrouve à aller travailler pour
aider sa mère à éduquer ses cinq frères
et soeurs
imaginez un instant le courage de cette
femme elle l'a fait et puis quelques
années plus tard donc sur cette photo
comme vous pouvez le constater je suis
déjà à l'époque très charmant
j'ai une bonne tête sympathique j'ai
déjà des grosses joues tout va bien les
cheveux qui vont bien je suis un petit
garçon heureux très heureux
en fait à cette époque et jusqu'à l'âge
de mes cinq ans tout va bien si ce n'est
le fait que mon père biologique n'a pas
souhaité faire partie de ma vie et n'a
pas souhaité me connaître je suis
entouré et c'est peut-être la chance de
ma vie de femme
je suis un pourri de ma grand mère
formidable grand-mère comme toutes les
grands mères réunionnaise je suis
entouré de ma mère et de mes tantes et
je ne manque de rien je ne manque ni
d'amour ni de bienveillance c'est de ça
dont il s'agit depuis ce matin d'amour
et de bienveillance
alors tout se passe bien pour moi je
suis entre de bonnes mains
et puis mon destin moi aussi bascule
plus tard
quelques années plus tard ma mère décide
de refaire sa vie et elle rencontre un
homme cet homme rentre dans ma vie c'est
pas mon père c'est mon père adoptif et
mon enfance eut marqué par beaucoup
d'événements alors je me mets au rugby
et là j'y trouve une femme une vraie
famille le rugby c'est on le dit souvent
c'est l'école de la vie
c'est aussi dans ce sport qu'on apprend
les valeurs les valeurs d'engagement de
solidarité
je deviens dans ce sport également un
jour exemplaires je progresse et les
qualités techniques et éthiques ne
laisse pas indifférent les entraîneurs
mais il ya une notion qui les marquent
surtout c'est cette notion de
combativité que j'ai développé un point
des fois qui n'a pas laissé toujours de
bons souvenirs à mes adversaires
souvent il disait qu'il valait mieux
être dans l'équipe que contre moi
j'étais un vrai guerrier et toute cette
haine et cette colère que j'avais dans
la vie je là je la mettais sur le
terrain dans mon engagement
j'ai travailler travailler travailler
parce que j'avais envie de partir de
tout ça j'avais envie de voir autre
chose j'avais envie de m'ouvrir sur
autre chose et puis la chance me réussit
c'est très vite offerte à moi à 17 ans
je suis repéré et je pars en france
jouer dans une équipe et je suis le
premier réunionnais à intégrer une
section de sport-études rugby alors je
prends l'avion pour la première fois je
suis content parce que c'est nouveau ça
y est je parle du bordel tout va bien
dans ce trajet qui me mène à bordeaux je
je suis là je je me demande comment ça
va se passer est ce que je vais avoir le
niveau que moi j'ai hâte de voir mes
camarades et également ils ont hâte de
me voir parce qu'on leur a dit il ya il
ya un réunionnais qui arrive un golgoth
se disent un réunionnais donc forcément
c'est un black et puis il décide donc de
me donner un surnom un petit surnom
avant que j'arrive ce surnom c'est
mamadou
j'arrive le voilà alors j'ai plutôt une
tête de wallisien qu'une date
d'africains j'ai rien contre les
africains j'adore mais je ne sais pas
typé africain donc je leur dire écoutez
vous avez décidé de m'appeler mamadou
qu'à cela ne tienne je serai votre
mamadou et puis on y va comme ça je suis
quand même aussi marqué on arrivé en
métropole par les moqueries que des fois
nous avons nous faisons les frais nous
devient on m'a souvent demandé si à la
réunion joue au rugby avec des noix de
coco au moins aussi souvent demandé si
on joue avec des tongs
le problème fut vite réglé à satie
connecter le commandant comment créer à
lille et eybens est la goutte à moi
donc du coup je suis passé de mama do uh
oh super copains et on le paye et le
café voilà ça a été souvent comme ça
dans la vie en fait donc tout va bien
et puis peu de temps après je rentre à
la réunion je viens en vacances je viens
en vacances avec un billet d'avion aller
retour et puis avec un contrat je dois
continuer ma carrière professionnelle
professional encore mais ma carrière de
joueur de rugby de haut niveau et je
rencontre mon ami de l'époque ma petite
amie de l'époque tout va bien on passe
de bons moments ensemble et au moment de
repartir assez
il ya quelque chose qui me bloque je
peux pas je peux pas y aller parce que
voilà on a échangé puis je découvre sa
vie je découvre des choses que j'avais
pas vu et je peux pas partir et la
laisser là donc je décide de rester je
me marie avec elle on est marié depuis
25 ans on a trois enfants
je démarre dans la vie active plus bas
de l'échelle
je travaillais en bureau d'étude j'avais
juste le bac j'ai toujours l'image de ma
mère qui était allé travailler à l'âge
de 14 ans qui n'avait pas eu la chance
d'étudier
je lui avais fait la promesse de faire
des études
donc durant des années je travaille la
journée je fais mon boulot de
techniciens et le soir je reprends des
cours le soir je vais m'entraîner et
pendant des années je repasse mes
diplômes jusqu'à ce que j'arrive à avoir
le niveau d'ingénieur
j'ai travailler travailler travailler
sans cesse parce que j'avais toujours ce
besoin de reconnaissance
j'arrivais pas à voir chez l'autre dans
le regard de l'autre la reconnaissance
du gal j'étais venu parce que moi
j'étais parti de très loin en fait
et j'avais beau travail et j'avais beau
avoir des diplômes j'avais l'impression
que tout le monde s'en foutait et qu'on
me voyait toujours comme ce petit
technicien qui avait démarré quelques
années plus tôt et en 2003 ce fut pour
moi la consécration en fait je deviens
directeur d'un bureau d'études
techniques à la réunion qui est filiale
d'un grand groupe français qui
s'implante à la réunion là je met tout
le monde d'accord ok là maintenant c'est
bon c'est clair j'ai le niveau j'y suis
j'aurais pu faire mon boulot et puis
continuer à faire ma carrière mais non
il fallait que je travaille encore
j'avais encore besoin de prouver j'avais
encore besoin de démontrer les choses je
n'étais pas préparée à ces fonctions je
n'étais pas préparée à gérer des hommes
et des femmes
je n'étais pas préparée à discuter avec
des commissaires aux comptes en fin
d'année mais les valeurs du rugby le
travail
l'exemplarité toutes ces valeurs qui ont
fait l'homme que je suis mon permis de
relever ces défis à chaque fois à chaque
fois et en 2009
en 2009 c'est moi sur la photo je suis
au siège de bayer aux urgences j'ai
perdu 17 kilos en deux semaines et je
suis frappé par la maladie à vouloir
prouver aux autres que j'étais bon voilà
je suis arrivé et à ce moment là j'étais
seul moi qui avais été bienveillants
généreux envers les autres
soudainement je vous retrouve seul j'ai
pas un pote j'epère sur le tour de moi
je suis seul et je prends conscience que
mon objectif de départ mais deux
objectifs de départ qui était faire des
études créer une famille et avoir des
enfants et les aimer j'étais passé à
côté de tous alors les études c'est bon
je les avais fait effectivement mais
j'avais passé à côté l'essentiel à côté
de ma famille est à côté de mes enfants
et là je cherche désespérément de l'aide
je cherche désespérément à soutien et le
soutien
le soutien c'est ma fille fanny c'est
elle c'est elle qui me fait prendre
conscience de ce qui est important dans
la vie c'est pas l'argent c'est pas les
diplômes c'est ce que vous êtes
c'est l'amour la bienveillance c'est ce
que vous pouvez apporter comme bonheur à
ceux qui sont autour de vous c'est ça le
plus important
alors je décide enfin de réagir pour
changer je reprends mes études à jamais
inscrits à l'université à paris xii bon
port ce coup-ci là je décide de faire
vraiment un truc utile et en 2011 en
pleine période de crise je décide de
créer ma société
à ce moment là
fort de tout ce que j'avais vécu je me
pose une question essentielle
je suis je suis je décide d'être un
acteur engagé dans le développement
durable dans les problématiques
environnementales
je me demande comment faire en sorte que
la crise les remises en questions liées
à la crise environnementale peuvent être
une occasion de créer des opportunités
permettant de régler la crise économique
et sociale
voilà la question que je me pose enfin
je me posais de bonnes questions
alors je prends un deuxième engagement
c'est de m'occuper de moi donc je crée
la boîte et je pars en vacances
c'était pas mal hein fatah enfin ça
commençait à rentrer et et je pars en
afrique du sud je pars dans les
montagnes de drague nbm chez mon ami
françois et là on découvre la nature on
re découvre la vie et je me redécouvre
et je me réconcilie avec beaucoup de
choses je reviens et puis je comprends
que ce qui m'avait souvent posé problème
aussi c'était cette ouverture aux autres
j'avais été le leader je disais comment
il fallait faire et tout mais j'étais
pas si bien que ça use that donc ceux
d'agen besoin d'ouverture a besoin
d'ouverture mais immense et j'ai inscrit
dans les gènes de mon entreprise la
notion d'export de régionalisation de
son activité
je décide que mon territoire c'est par
la réunion c'est pas huit cent mille
habitants
c'est tout le continent africain c'est
tout l'océan indien et je me dis que
contrairement à ce qu'on dit souvent
qu'à la réunion on a des handicaps la
langue est un handicap que on a
développé ici quelque chose qui est
essentiel l'actualité récente nous
montre qu'on a raison on a développé ici
quelque chose qui s'appelle le vivre
ensemble
ça veut dire qu'on était capable
d'accepter la différence de l'autre et
de fer avec l'autre la différence
enrichi de la différence de l'autre on
est tous complémentaires
alors je développe les activités
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance de travailler
sur des sujets qui me tiennent à coeur
je travaille avec mes équipes avec mes
partenaires avec mes camarades
scientifiques sur les questions sur le
changement climatique
nous travaillons sur une étude sur les
effets du changement climatique sur les
villes côtières en afrique de l'ouest et
sur la côte la côte ouest et centrale
quand on travaille sur ces sujets on
prend quand plus conscience de cette
notion de changement et d'ouverture aux
autres
on prend aussi conscience qu'à la
réunion on est privilégié parce qu'on
est situé entre l'asie et le continent
africain
c'est une chance inouïe parce qu'à la
réunion il ya des savoir faire
cet amphithéâtre est un savoir-faire
mondiale à la réunion il ya une jeunesse
formée il ya des chefs d'entreprises qui
n'ont pas encore compris qu'ils
pouvaient s'appuyer sur cette jeunesse
mais le potentiel est là on prend
conscience quand on fait ses études de
la gravité de l'activité humaine sur
l'environnement et sur l'écologie et sur
les drames que ça génère que ça produit
on prend conscience que le dérèglement
climatique c'est un pack l'agriculture
la pêche et notamment sur le continent
africain
est ce un pack notamment les femmes
parce qu'elles sont à la base de
l'économie de ces pays les femmes
alors aujourd'hui je fais quelque chose
qui me plaît je fais des choses qui ont
un sens pour moi
et j'essaye de trouver du temps pour
tout la semaine dernière enfin cette
semaine par dont j'étais en afrique du
sud
je suis avec des amis pour la plupart ce
sont des joueurs d'afrique du sud déjà
springboks qui ont joué en équipe
nationale
on a créé une fondation qui permet
d'éduquer des enfants 5000 enfants
exactement qui sont atteintes du virus
du vih pour certains pour d'autres qui
ont été agressées sexuellement flotte
qui était dans l'alcoolisme ou la drogue
et moi je me suis engagé à y passer une
demi-journée ou une journée à chaque
déplacement au me rendre dans ces écoles
parce que je considère aujourd'hui que
l'éducation est la base de tout
je pourrais vous donner des tas de
messages mais le temps est court et je
dois laisser aussi aux autres la
possibilité de s'exprimer puisque il
nous est permis aujourd'hui de lancer un
message sur internet et sur à travers
internet touché également les
réunionnais qui sont un peu éparpillée
partout dans le monde
je voudrais que vous associez - c'est
tous vous lever s'il vous plaît c'était
pas prévu un david à voilà donc là on
est filmé donc tout le monde nous voit
sur internet
vous allez vous prendre la main tous
voient là et on va montrer au monde
entier ce que c'est que une société
multiculturelle une société qui est
faite de métissage la réunion c'est ça
c'est ça la réunion de demain c'est la
réunion debout ensemble fiers les uns
des autres et non une réunion dit viser
une réunion où c'est vous qui choisissez
allez politique c'est vous c'est vous
les hommes les femmes de demain les
jeunes filles et les jeunes garçons
c'est vous voilà voilà l'image la
réunion c'est ça la réunion c'est pas
les attentes à la réunion c'est la
tolérance
merci